destiny 2 is finally out and we've
gathered these sassiest Guardians on the
GameSpot team for Destiny's children a
weekly let's play series in which we'll
be shooting and looting our way through
the galaxy on this week's episode we
uncover the secrets of the farm and meet
a raving Falcon we bite off more than we
can chew in a high ranked public event I
don't think we should be here the bullet
it does nothing and dave goes all
mission impossible trying to sneak past
some trip wires do I shot one you scum
so first things first there's a secret
mission in here okay if you've not been
on the internet then you may not know
this but if you've been on any sort of
website gaming-related you've been
inundated was it where is it mission so
first is the the wheel as a wheeler the
war wheel yeah okay
ready in about this before so you need
to get into the middle okay okay and
then jump onto the roof oh I can't Jones
actually quite like it you've got like
Oh get in the middle yeah so you get in
the middle of the wheel the middle I'm
like a hamster okay port yep now what
and then I don't yeah how much harder
than you think like the jumping is
really weird
this reminds me oddly flowy and
sometimes they'll grab onto things oh
I'm bouncing a grade of thing you know
in Dark Souls 3 when you could get into
the tower without having the key yeah
and then they patched it out so once
you're on the roof yeah jump back onto
the wheel okay and walk back a bit and
you've basically to run on the wheel for
a few seconds I'm watching Dave do this
keep you I keep at it
Oh century regs to just pop oh you've
got a century rank - now listen used to
do it wheel booths completed said she
writes - okay now we do know a scene for
that feel like having three of us in
here must be a disaster
pirate scared yeah so now we need to
follow me so now we need to all jump
onto this it's a cable with your cable
in along it oh god oh god
this is the real destiny experience wait
I have to get that Shh
no just run all the way across it yeah
run all the way across it
I did that know what how do you get your
first time skills and then you need to
do it on this one which is trickier
because you've got a jump on to the
actual coddling well oh my what is that
wall jump thing by the way
oh yeah there you go now you've got
super job now you've got it
okay shinespark said you wrecked for it
isn't easy to do this slowly or quickly
I did it quickly I'm probably okay now I
could run fast now love you basically
you've got the ability to jump way
higher I send out no Lucy there's
another yeah so you can jump real higher
okay hands over this way what purpose so
you can explore more of the farm by also
because you now have okay okay I bought
it's okay I thought I was gonna drop you
are technically dropping there so the
ostensibly you use it to explore more
areas in the farm right but also because
you now have a century rank for you can
go to that fire pit okay this thing was
this this the only thing that I have to
get up here I mean you've got sentry
right so now you can do the activities
and the touch of the fire pit scouting
patrol yeah okay lammed itself into the
ground also they jump Israel turned red
I am I've turned blue I need my butt is
sorry I'm a robe are bullsh I know ten
minutes lay off okay save like judo's
County Patrol yeah was it a no idea nice
just like that oh wait isn't this your
wait there's a little Waypoint here
yeah that's the mission we fish do the
mission no no there was a big big blue
glow a bit what is it saying you need
scouting surgery before this is glowing
why is it doing this to me oh it says
I'm on a scouting patrol but it's also
saying
I need such career I have century four
there's no baby
I think you've activated it that's why
you're out okay yeah I say we do the
story mission yeah let me jump with your
head go on
set it for the Senate phone wait a
second let's go how do I get a if you
jump my head I mean I've just used the
stairs no that's boring no in a week
hello who's that Falcon that's Captain
Falcon show me your moves she wants to
help you out she's a cool guy she's just
trying to help you out Tata for them no
you just have to accept a mission with
everything we can go it's Falcons about
to eat my [ __ ] I do have a weird idea
what is this all about
oh yeah the things for Luis isn't it
yeah Luis Isaac I love it when animals
have human names Lois the room
Lois through well he's technically
refugees all right let's get the corn
the mission well how do you go from
Samson did you import your character I
did maybe I was told not to hey
unbelievable no I didn't actually but
like I said so I can't explain why this
is how can we put so much speed mellow
this darude sandstorm now
let's go what I mean Grabavoy yeah all
right sunshine lows big ships right away
Wow
all right very good you got to go into
this church started flowing it's all
finished
it's just flow it over like a mini-boss
it's mini-boss let me shoot him in the
brain all right this is him here
wham wham wham pick up great band
collect loot honestly like the plunder
ddz token some level 20 dude hang out
with us
is it our last no slowly the warlock
dance is lame look at me how to dance is
great Titan dance is very sense you
dance it I'm gonna climb this church
tower oh yeah it's a sniper let's blow
it up Friedrich Salah previous destiny I
barely ever bought Luke always just
deleted it yeah okay this pro snips over
here
where we use when we were fighting the
bad guys so my ghost has a new skinny
he's so legit recognize that voice like
I recognize this guy's voice as well
yeah we gonna IMDB check please what's
his name
I don't know dead zone big dude Deborah
his name is different
huge enemy time yes he's just gonna be a
guy where are you I'll give you a healed
devran k is he incredible he is put like
a weird accident ID yeah he's good while
the games has he been in though I wonder
from crumb is wonder crumb on the chump
come in come on punch in the face okay
turtle you come to the dank tunnel noise
please do this enemies this guy just
saved my supercharged light saber for
Windows let me know when you want to
IMDB shield least you got heels right
yeah I'm just gonna tell you by the way
don't get used to the IMDB filled but
there's I'm gonna spec towards offense
as soon as like right well I'm gonna I'm
gonna if you guys cover me are gonna go
in hunter lightsaber deployed let's go
don't teleport away from me Arisa shield
barrier that guy in this fight well I
love you but uh earlier shot at immunity
me a damage point 69 nice pretty gonna
happen a lot
whoa what was that that's the power of
might have shine red barrel you know
video games
I like the red barrels yeah
you two there's three of us someone here
has been ostracized from the group
already a new Han sook love zone a lot
gonna do the public event that's
starting in one minute yes absolutely
don't they found the public all right
you follow me then where is it
it says over here what am i driving
public ether resupply arts over here
it's over here oh yeah oh dang
my level of these enemies Oh they've got
big red things next to them I don't
think we should be here that's got
spikes
should we have high level what the
bullet it does nothing
yeah but it's our okay but there's like
nope I'm nowhere near sick sick sick
sick sick sick sick sick sick sick no no
the Beast
oh wait got to take down the big thing
yeah I mean take us forever
we'll just leech up a loop Oh or if you
destroy the little ones you can do it
like a special public event version of
this i'ma let you take it off 12.2
attacking I scored for them it's all hi
rice that heat heals well you come me
come here get me on the IMDB he'll we
sheet to the RDP you
why the things I will avoid tomorrow's
great advantage oh those level 20 is
still talking about well I thought I
believe they call that there's never 20
guys just like what these nerds doing
yeah we are helping I thought his name
was the pendant business oh yeah it says
Tata Tata lay claim Destiny instead of
making me for our games you can buy
bonds off him get to work Todd Wow I am
fully daddy guys please res regular race
oh man I mean real good when you punch
him yeah in real life
leave me alone impactor why I'm shooting
the big guy any to me we've got just
focus fire it as soon as it's not music
shooting the big blue eye what what
what's helping me the enemy she ended it
in the center oh here we go here we go
there we go where we rest in pieces
captain rectifier charging for life
Allah give me the loot give me the loop
final justice at least it's a cape I
think she got her cape called at least
it's a cape we were we should not have
been able to do that if this level 20
here it wasn't here we would have been
what our luck should we do the big red
mission oh here we go here we go
oh no no no in a minute and do that I
was shooting enemies
my captain my captain they throw a
grenade at me I'm ready Morrie's done it
yeah just killed a bunch of them
I got some boots at least two pairs
let's roll
but yours I feel flowing about though
yeah
oh it's nice all the vegetation the way
don't be some patience and welcome to
signal boosters oh you have a job have
you tried jumping and jumping again it's
just cake where are you friend-zoned an
evolutional universe around you can help
him yeah I'm stuck I was trying to jump
up here but you just went outside this
way well organically save
actually I quite like galaxies so
sometimes when you get it in America it
tastes like soap which is most American
chocolate it tastes bad
sorry Americans watching I know there's
quite a few of you but your chocolate is
diabolical both red vines and whatever
you have wonderful twist those
disgusting they are just wax there are
war just savory snacks are on point
yeah yes every snacks are Oh Cheney
flips we talk about clips recite Oh
the pretzels actually could we dogs I'm
starving yeah
in summary fairly sweet snacks are the
savory is legit I'm not a fan of
Twinkies you know know their hostess
Russell we better get on up or hair
loses what Twinkies are elite and open
snack
just because they got fetishized in
Zombieland alright I've never actually
eaten one that gross no like stinky food
yummy Oh what was it I got obsessed with
last time we're in America a goes there
goes yeah you said Lego if I go yeah
those what I was eating like for a day
yeah which is the appear me of health
yeah listen and just listen to me now I
love n goes all the time I just want to
be like 11 I wanna have powers I'll
refold no I've got bigger balls yeah
to open doors have a little bear heels
please I can give you the ID to put my
heel down he said I just slid here
yourself on these sick moves you do you
think that's my first video game disturb
your laughs it'll be a lot of fun
spoiler I've got it when Lucy was in
proximity though great Microban section
that was oh I'm still upset that didn't
get accepted
oh there's some absolute trash unnerves
in urban dictionary and I put in
Microban section and they did not accept
it they're like this is two borders
Richard don't die I never measure what
he said reminds me of paid
oh yeah let us my part will be players
picked up the dead zone snipe artful I'm
gonna use the IMDB field I am Debbie she
is thick
is it a recess you already have I'm oh
come on no way it's that big I don't
think he treats you pretty you know I
think maybe if you never retreat the
effect on it is really nice though okay
and it's this guy oh I still gotta get
out
okay thank you I fell I fallen and I
can't get it until Dave picks me up
thank you I just I just a gun told stay
away he's gay god no don't hug me
oh my god one of these guys in Nier
automata whoa alright this is a weapon I
can get behind
what a weapon I'm just gonna jump down
there with his on the platen as well has
died from for that wish I am boots on
the ground I'm built a punch hit rio+
yes
oh there's a lot more here there lads
yeah wow I'm so glad I do do I shot one
you scum did I
I was totally mission to pasta building
it's the easiest way to disarm of it I'm
he's not wrong he did the smart thing
there save us a lot of time and effort
let's go all it took was like a big
chunk of my soul binds the floor is just
yes meet me in st. Louis but it's a bad
day as soon as I push this there's gonna
be a bunch of waves coming like water
waves or that's ghost can you get out
please finish
turn it over and chocolate crack a joke
oh yeah Oh healthy resilient dress I'm
gonna pop the IMDB shell here we loaded
by slipper riffle I need no scope that
guy I mean by living a BB shot some
color someone to grab my way I just
wanted to call this Wow
taste the rainbow oh oh no he's getting
boosted okay oh yeah it's the open boost
it's the most awesome
that's the wholesome card opening the
one where you get is it the black dahlia
he gets the black dahlia yeah like I'm
gonna play grounder something paint
magic everything just can play those
finally know what that discover who
killed Elizabeth sure his reaction is
still finding the mic but yeah when he
got that black White Lotus okay hold oh
that thing is with like tens of
thousands of dollars forty wage doesn't
make that man videos anymore hey my
wildest dreams see that mother you said
playing my dick together in cars I'll
never get me anywhere
I've open Buster that's not for that
that's not plugging open boosters
sweets episode of Destiny's children one
for to you by some reason those
mattresses together listen to so many
podcasts that are sponsored by Casper
and those I couldn't sleep
oh they're above us I was trying to
figure out like what their overheads
must yeah if they could sell mattresses
so cheap I'm getting one of it every
part of like out Davis like in a
desperate fight for survival against the
fallen and sponsored by Cassidy what
someone's gonna keep us alive right oh I
just knocked out vaudeville off the
ledge see you later
and when we're done today is actually
pretty garbage just to be clear this is
not in any way awesome I actually have
no idea my mattress is very good it oh
who does my mattress it's so good it was
like half off so good rather mine let's
let's go let's finish hooking up all
right all right you didn't make me a cup
of tea you made the company thank you
rub it in our face in Glen Ian Glen from
Resident Evil One and to the movies
if you remember I couldn't get with the
Red Queen in that movie either friend
zone it's like Sean Bean dies in every
movie England's friends and every
conceivable fictional universe they
exist how'd your iPad got your [ __ ] up I
make this how can a falcon owe you money
have you ever been in debt to a falcon
you they get vicious
it's not pecking at you I look so evil I
have definitely as if my character is
hot yes we have the same both in the
game on a Marilla Oh Lulu cutscene big
red logo it does this every time it cut
through this character wait I thought
the speaker was bill 9 is angry lost
this sci-fi bade he looks like thinking
of wait he's got a good reason to cover
that face they just see earlier when the
other guy look like is that a mouth was
just like a moving I know looks a bit
like a futuristic looks like the guy
from Mad Max yeah it looks like a mix
between like in what and Joe and a
character from a Star Wars The Old
Republic here
also it looks like an evil buff little
kids try to trap it
right who's this voice it used to be
bill 9i it's nice yeah the speaker used
to be bill night just open license -
never was he the guy who was in
underworld I don't know what that was
the first movie that was I'm at but what
if it has so many more better movies
that's not the kid's mind possibly this
is bidded Bill Nye the Best Exotic
Marigold Hotel and it's equalled was it
Harry Potter yes every British I wasn't
sure I'll let you know obviously the
best thing the Bill Nyes ever done or
been involved with is Meerkat Manor it's
a program that just follows meerkats
around in Africa and Bill Nye does the
commentary and there's this incredible
bit where he goes and here we see the
meerkats practicing their combat skills
well it's like these big wings he's got
angry Blas is getting really upset about
stuff here
he is so boy his head genuinely looks
like a pale testicle that's gross
tell me I'm wrong why does it do this
every single time previously I was like
32 it's like the transition in the
Batman TV series it was a waste load we
did that one should we do one more
little adventure while we're here before
we call it today a frame job we get some
carbon iron we get distracted by the
loop when I walk away the Waypoint is
its back on him 930 six damage of a head
shot hello hello
you know divvy it up track of the right
thing also works this we know this this
door here god it's like a weird fog a
boy said that's a good dog sauce for K
oh this is cool so we all sat in a trap
I'm gonna switch out my fragments why do
we get these fragments from just just to
defeat random fool that I guess oh
there's one that's easy
there's another one looks like for every
fold and you kill you just can't look
all right I got six through Grenada
degree without five people who can go to
Salt Mines we go lads
it's like put on the crime already happy
mo binds everywhere oh good my favorite
it's not ready adorable when you alright
let me see if I can sneak through these
nobody very Q alright Mission Impossible
style ah the enemy plays Shaab slide
slow we in there lads Dave oh that
wasn't me exactly Bob that never fine oh
how did that what's himself backed up in
some places they're back up the truck
time for some cnxn to start at all well
material explosion over there best see
my right over there
oh this is the amber Cyrus light and
mica have the explosives all right great
teleporters while you're asleep all
right get to the cliffs watch out for
cliff edge transmit any away from that
guy what well alright
whatever works some glorious head shots
going on
[Applause]
dodged right into the boy he's gonna add
anything I really like these guys purple
threads
I'm not wildly in love with these guys
well honey what's the least likable who
are you is it Tully my Miranda got the
Bowie to be perfect all right I love
this Wow look at what Nolan bunch done
interesting let's put a little spray
paint naturally yeah he's just putting
loads of oh now some reason we can't
restore all right it's final stone stand
now oh oh they will work jetpacks let's
go great what oh all right a guy in the
face the other side no la da oh great ah
bloody hell you see if you go seen the
thing for the gladiator sequel the
time-travel one yeah yeah
that's right sounds like a great movie
oh yeah petrova no look dinklebot spoon
oh it's not dinklebot Emily's puttin
Morin sniper rifle rounds the crushing
fest is now they're sick gold over my
guy there you go though torture room you
have what feels and looks like a
lightsaber him I've got another cape
called at least it's okay yeah I guess
we're done for the day
so that was Episode one of Destiny's
children if you want to see more of
destiny to make sure to subscribe as
we'll be doing weekly live streams every
Tuesday and continuing the madness of
our let's play series every Friday let
us know you're burning destiny questions
or what you want to see us get up to on
the series in the comments below or by
finding us all on Twitter thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time